hey everyone it's Sarah threads sterner
sorry n comm and today we're going to
talk about canes and as always after you
get done watching this YouTube video you
can access the free quiz that will test
you on this assistive device so let's
get started when you're studying these
assistive devices for exams you want to
make sure that you know those key
concepts about those devices such as
canes crutches and walkers and in our
previous video we talked about crutches
and in our next video we'll talk about
walkers so for canes you want to make
sure that you're familiar with how a
cane should properly fit a patient how
to actually walk with a cane how a
patient should go up and down stairs
with a cane and how they should get up
from a chair or sit down in a chair with
the cane therefore let's start with the
proper fit how do you know as the nurse
of this cane actually fits your patient
well before a patient uses a cane for
the first time it has to be adjusted
most canes can be adjusted at the bottom
by sliding the cane into location of
where it should go to fit the patient
but once the patient is holding the cane
or once they have the cane standing
beside their body how do you know it
actually fits the patient well there's
two ways you can tell the first way is
that the top of the cane which is about
this area here should be even with the
great trochanter the great trochanter is
a prominence of the femur so that's all
the cane should rest about right there
whenever the patient's standing up and
has the cane beside of them or the top
of the cane should be even with the
wrist crease that is closest to the hand
so those are two ways you can tell also
whenever the patient is holding the cane
the elbows should be flexed at a fifteen
to thirty degree angle so those are some
things that you can look for as the
nurses tell you that this cane properly
fits your patient now let's talk about
how a patient should walk with the cane
before a patient starts using their cane
and practicing with it you want to make
sure that
they are wearing a gait belt for safety
in addition you're going to stand on the
patient's weak side in case they lose
their balance so whenever they start
using the cane they want to make sure
that they're in the proper position the
position that they want to be in they
want to make sure that they are
positioning the tip of the cane at least
four inches from the side of the foot
and they want to hold the cane on the
strong side of the body so remember that
the cane needs to be on the strong side
very important concept to remember so
how are they going to actually ambulate
with this cane well to emulate with the
cane what they're going to do is they're
going to move the cane with the weak
side together forward so they move the
cane along with their weak side together
and then they will move the strong side
forward
so how does a patient go up and down the
stairs with a cane well the concept is
the same like how we learned with
crutches remember I told you to remember
up equals good down equals bad and what
we're referring to is the good leg going
up first which would be the strong leg
versus whenever we're going down this
stairs it would be the bad leg that's
going to go first
so the weak side therefore how do we go
up the stairs using that concept well
what the patient wants to do is they
want to hold the cane on that good slash
strong side then they're going to move
the good leg up onto the step and
they're gonna put weight onto the cane
and then move the cane and the bad leg
up onto the step now to go down the
stairs the patient again is going to
hold the cane on the good side that
strong side they're gonna move the cane
down onto the step with the bad leg so
the bad leg is going down then they're
going to move the good leg down onto the
step and lastly let's talk about how a
patient will sit down and get up using a
cane to sit down with a cane the patient
is going to back up to the chair until
he fills the chair with the back of the
legs then the patient will allow the
cane to rest on the side of the chair
and place both hands on the chairs
armrest and place weight on the hands
while keeping the weak leg extended out
and been the strong leg to sit down to
sit up with the cane a patient's going
to place the cane on the strong side and
lean forward in the chair while keeping
the weak leg slightly extended forward
then the patient's going to push down on
the canes hand grip and the chair
armrest and then put weight on the
strong leg and stand in position with
the cane thank you so much for watching
don't forget to take the free quiz and
to subscribe to our channel for more
videos